okay you've uh you're one of the most
productive people I know
uh what what's the secret to your
productivity how do you uh maximize the
number of productive hours in a day your
scientist your teacher you're a very
prolific educator
well thanks for the kind words I
struggle like everybody else but I
um I'm pretty
Relentless about
meeting deadlines oh I miss them
sometimes but sometimes that means
cramming sometimes that means starting
early but has that been hard it's hard
to interrupt with the podcast you uh
there's certain episodes
I mean you're like taking just
incredibly difficult topics and you know
they're going to be there's going to be
a lot of really good scientists
listening to those with a very skeptical
and careful eye
like how hard do you struggle meeting
that deadline sometimes yes we've pushed
out episodes because I want more time
with them I also I haven't advertised
this um but I have another
of fully tenured professor that's
started um checking my my
um podcasts and helping me
um find papers he's a close friend of
mine he's an incredible expert in
neuroplasticity and that's been helpful
but I researched all my all I do all the
primary research for the episodes myself
although my niece has been doing a
summer internship with me and finding
amazing papers she did last summer as
well she's really good at it
um just stick that kid on the internet
and she gets great stuff
um just going on tangents here
what's the hardest finding the papers or
understanding what a paper is saying or
finding finding the best papers yeah
because you have to you know you read a
bunch of reviews figure out who's
getting cited call people in a field
make sure that this is the stuff I mean
you know I did this episode recently on
ketamine about ketamine I wasn't on
ketamine and um and you know there's
this whole debate about s versus our kid
I mean srk I mean and I called two
clinical experts at Stanford I had a
researcher at UCLA helped me even then
you know a few people had gripes about
it that I don't think they understood a
section that I was perhaps could have
been clear about
um but yeah you you're always concerned
that people won't either won't get it or
I won't be clear so that the researching
is mainly about finding the best papers
and then I'm looking for papers that
establish thoroughness of understanding
um that are interesting obviously it's
fun to get occasionally look at some of
the odd or more Progressive papers that
are you know what's new in a field and
then where there are actionable
takeaways to to Really
um export those with with a lot of
thoughtfulness I mean I think that
um going back to the productivity thing
um you know I I do I get up I look at
the sun I I don't stare at the Sun but I
get my sunshine I it all starts with a
really good night's sleep I think that's
really important to understand so much
so that if I wake up and I don't feel
rested enough I'll often do a non-sleep
depressed Yoga Nidra or go back to sleep
for a little bit get up really
prioritize one you know the big block of
work for the thing that I'm researching
I think a little bit of anxiety and a
little bit of concern about deadline
helps
um turning the phone off helps
um
realizing that those peak hours whenever
they are for you you you do not allow
those hours to be invaded unless there's
a you know a nuclear bomb goes off
um and
and nuclear bomb is just a you know a
phraseology for um you know it could be
family crisis would be and you know
would be a good justification if there's
an emergency obviously but
um it's all about Focus it's all about
focus in the moment it's not even so
much about
um how many hours you log it's really
about focusing about how much total
focus can you give to something and then
I like to take walks and think about
things
um and sometimes talk about them in my
voice recorder so I'm just always
churning on it all the time and um
and then of course learning to turn it
off and engage with people socially and
you know not not be podcasting 24 hours
a day in your head is key but I think I
love learning and researching and
finding that those papers and the
information and I love teaching it and
these days I use a whiteboard before I
start I don't have any notes no
teleprompter then the white board that I
use beforehand is to really sculpt out
the different elements and and the flow
get the flow right and move things
around the the Whiteboard is such a
valuable tool then take a couple
pictures of that
when I'm happy with it put it down on
the desk and these are just bullet
points and then just churn through and
just turn through and nothing feels
better than you know researching and
sharing information and and I and as you
did you know grew up writing papers and
it it's hard and I like the friction of
like uh can't you know I want to get up
when he's about when I was in College I
was trying to make up deficiencies from
my lack of attendance in high school
so much so that I I would set a timer I
wouldn't let myself get up to use the
bathroom even never had an accident but
I was you know I mean it's like I
listened to music classical music rancid
a few other things some Bob Dylan maybe
thrown in there
um and just study and and it felt and
then you know hit the two hour mark and
you're in pain and then you get up yeah
like use the bathroom like that felt so
good there's something about the human
brain that likes these kind of friction
points and working through them and you
just have to work through them so yeah
I'm productive and and my life has
arranged around it and you know that's
been a bit of a barrier to personal life
at times but my life's been arranged
around it I've set up everything so that
I can learn more teach more
um including
you know some of my home life and
um but I do you know still watch chimp
Empire still got time to watch Jim Bob
look the great Joe Strummer
all right Clash or my favorite
mescaleros he said you know this famous
drummer quote no input no output
so you need you need experience you need
outside things in order to Foster the
the process but
uh yeah just nose to the grindstone man
I don't know I don't I don't know and
that's what and that's what I'm happy to
do with my life I don't think anyone
should do that just because but this is
how I'm showing up and you know if you
don't like me then Scrolls whether they
say swipe left sorry right I don't know
I'm not on the apps the dating apps so
that's the other thing I keep waiting
for when um
listens to like Friedman podcast is a
check box on like hinge or Bumble or
whatever it is but I don't even know are
those that are field is I don't know
what that what are the apps now I've
never used an app and I I I those
file Troublesome how little information
is provided on apps well they're the
ones that are like a stocked Lake like
like Raya you know it's like that they
like they sort of like companies will
actually fill them with uh people that
look a certain way and well soon it'll
be filled with AI oh yeah that's the way
you said oh yeah that's a hard break
within that well I you know I'm guilty
of liking real human interaction
that have you tried AI interaction
no but I have a feeling you're gonna
convince me too
one day
um yeah I've I've also struggled
finishing projects that are new there
are some something new
like for example some one of the things
I really struggled finishing is
something that's in Russian that
requires translation and overdub and all
that kind of stuff the other project
I've been working on for like over
at least a year
um off and on but trying to finish is
something we've talked about in the past
is I'm still on it uh project on Hitler
in World War II I've written so much
about it and I just don't know why I
can't finish it I have trouble like
really
um I think I'm terrified being in front
of the camera
like this like this or so well actually
no no no solo well if you want to do
solo and seriously because we've done
this before right our our clandestine uh
study missions I'll I'm happy to sit in
the corner and work on my book or do
something if you want to if it feels
good it's just just for the feeling of
somebody else definitely what do you I
mean how do you you don't seem to
you seem to have been Fearless to just
sit in front of the camera
by yourself to do the episode yeah it
was weird I mean the first year of the
podcast it just spilled out of me it was
just I had all that stuff I was so
excited about I've been talking to
everyone and who would listen and anyone
uh anyone who they run away I'd keep
talking you know before there was ever a
camera wasn't on social media 2019 I
posted a little bit 2020 as you know I
started going on podcast but yeah I had
so I just
I just
the zest and Delight in this stuff it's
like circadian rhythms I'm going to tell
you about this stuff I just felt like
here's the opportunity and just let it
burst and then as we've gotten into
topics that are a little bit further
away from my my um home knowledge you
know it the it's like
I still get super excited about it it's
music in the Brain Episode I've been
researching for a while now I'm just so
hyped like about it it's so so
interesting there's so many facets
singing versus improvation
improvisational excuse me music versus
I'm listening to music versus
um learning music I mean that it just
goes on and on there's just so much
that's so interesting I just can't get
enough and and I think
oh you put a camera in front of me I
sort of forget about it uh and I'm just
trying to just teach yes that's the
difference that's interesting I mean I
forget the camera maybe I need to find
that joy as well but like for me a lot
of the joys in the in the writing and uh
the the camera there's something well
the best lecturers as you know and
you're in a phenomenal lecturer so you
embody this as well but the when I teach
at Stanford I was directing this course
in neuroanatomy and Neuroscience and for
medical students and I noticed that the
best lecturers would come in and they're
teaching the material from a place of
deep understanding but they're also
experiencing it as a first-time learner
as at the same time so it's just sort of
embodying the Delight of it but also the
authority over them not Authority but
the the sort of Mastery of the material
and it's really the Delight in it that
the students are linking on to and of
course they need and deserve the best
accurate material so they have to know
what they're talking about but
um yeah just tap into that energy of
learning and loving it and people are
along for the ride or you know I get
accused of being long-winded but you
know things get taken out of context
that leads to Greater misunderstanding
and also I look at listen I come from a
lineage of three debt advisors three all
three
so I don't know when the reaper is
coming for me I'm doing my best to stay
alive a long time but whether or not
it's a bullet or a bus or
cancer or whatever or just old age I
mean I'm trying to get it all out there
as best I can and if it means you have
to hit pause and come back a day or two
later like that seems like a reasonable
compromise to me I'm not gonna go
um go longer than I need to and I'm
trying to shorten them up but uh again
that's that's kind of how I show up it's
like Tim Armstrong would say about
writing songs I asked him do you write
how often you write every day
every day was Rick ever stop creating no
is Joe ever stop preparing for comedy
are you ever stopping to think about
world issues and and technology and who
you can talk to I mean it seems to me
you've always got a plan
the inside the the thing I love about
your podcast the most
to be honest these days is the surprise
of like I don't know who the hell is
going to be there it's almost like like
I get a little nervously excited about
when a new episode comes because I have
no idea no idea and you know I mean I
have some guesses based on what you told
me during the break I mean yeah you've
got someone people where it's just like
whoa Lexus went there awesome can't wait
click you know there you know I think
that's really cool like you're
constantly surprising people so you're
doing it so well like it's such a high
level and I think it's also important
for people to understand that what
you're doing relax
there's no precedent for it sure there
have been interviews before there have
been podcasts before their discussions
before but it's not like how many of
your peers can you look to to find out
how best to do the content like yours
zero there's one peer you
and so you know that should give you
great peace and great excitement because
you're you're a Pioneer you're the
you're literally the tip of the spear I
I don't want to take an unnecessary
tangent but I think this might thread
together two of the things that we've
been talking about which are I think of
pretty key importance one is romantic
relationships and the other is creative
process and work and this again is
something I learned from Rick but that
he and I have gone back and forth on and
that
um I think is worth elaborating on which
is
earlier we're saying you know the best
relationship is going to be one where
you where it brings you peace I think
peace also can be translated to among
other things
lack of distraction so when you're with
your partner can you really focus on
them and the relationship
can you not be distracted by
things that you're upset about from
their past or from your past with them
or their and of course the same is true
for them right they ideally will feel
that way towards you too they can really
focus also
when you're not with them can you focus
on your work can you not be worried
about whether or not they're okay
because you trust that they're an adult
and they can handle things or they will
reach out if they need things
um they're going to communicate their
needs like an adult you know not
creating message just to get attention
and things like that or
or disappearing you know for that matter
so
peace and focus are intimately related
and distraction is the enemy of peace
and focus
so there's something there I believe
um because with people that have a
strong generative drive and and want to
you know be productive in their home
life in the sense have a rich family
life
um or partner life whatever that is and
in their work life
you know the ability to really drop into
the work and
like okay you might have that sense like
I hope they're okay or you know need to
check my phone or something but just
know like we're good yeah so so peace
and focus I think and present being
present are so key and it's key at every
level of romantic relationship from
um you know certainly presence and focus
you know everything from sex to
listening to
um to you know raising a family to
tending to the house
um and in work it's absolutely critical
so I think that those things are kind of
mirror images of the same thing and
they're both important reflections of
the other and when you start to just you
know when work is not going well then
the relationship the focus on
relationship can suffer and vice versa
so and it's crazy how important that is
oh
how incredibly
um uh wonderful it could be to have a
person in your life that kind of uh
enables that creative Focus yeah and you
supply the the peace and focus for their
Endeavors whatever those might be I mean
that that symmetry there
um because clearly people have different
needs and the need to just really trust
you know like when Lex is working he's
in his generative mode and and and I
know he's good and so then they they
feel sure they've contributed to that
but then also what you're doing is
supporting them in whatever way it
happens to be and I think that sometimes
you'll see that people will pair up
along creative creative or Musical
musical or
um computer scientists but I think again
going back to this Conti episode on on
relationships is that the superficial
labels are less important it seems than
just the desire to create that kind of
home life in a relationship together and
as a consequence the the work mode and
for some people there both people aren't
working and sometimes they are but I
think that's I think that's the good
stuff you know and and I think that's
the big learning in all of it is that
the further along I go with each
birthday I guarantee you're gonna be
like what I want is simpler and simpler
and harder and harder to to uh create
but oh so worth it